I'm very nervous about this just really
don't feel good about it
wait for people to get in here but damn
Blair Witch my dudes
all righty we are live hello everyone
I'm Ilana welcome to my channel where
today I'm streaming the end of Blair
which which is so far I haven't found
this game scary at all supposedly this
ending pot is super scary so I thought I
would stream it mostly because I need
the support it's really dark evidently
I'm kind of hallucinating and just so
you all know I make shot at
I just lost my dog who was the one
comfort I had in this hellscape but he
is now gone
there she is which is gonna be around
here somewhere ain't she
but yeah legit prior to the pride of
this I haven't found this game scary at
all I guess I still don't find this
scary I've just heard that the ending is
where the game gets scary so I'm nervous
about it if I hadn't heard I'd probably
be like yeah whatever it's more of the
same God dang woods what a whack hair
they talking about me
they definitely talk about me okay don't
know where I'm going but that's how the
games designed the noises make me think
I might be going the right way I don't
know if the dog died I carried uh to my
YouTube chat I carried the dog that
might actually be the noise of the dog I
carried the dog till I passed out the
dog heard itself I carried it until
we've passed out
I'm hoping the dogs still alive
somewhere is it the same tree it is okay
so now I go this way I think that's
still the dog whining I can hear but the
main character this game Ellis has PTSD
so he hallucinates all the time oh
what's this
Paul he has something on his shirt like
this okay that's a dead end
I don't really want to turn around if
I'm honest I don't feel great about how
he to shut her out okay it's fine okay I
don't know which way to go then oh is it
dead end again it is brilliant love it
oh this game hasn't had a single jump
scare I'm sweating it got all layers of
theory it is made by bloobity meeee
they're the same people who made [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't like this yeah it's made by
the same people who a believes afiyah I
don't think I can do anything I just
have to keep talking around okay it's
fine let's just get through it
[ __ ] you you goddamn video I can't see
anything else to interact with is and
I'm getting new audio so I'm doing
something right right so just the same
ol rocks-in-the-box con
is it seriously Oh
oh that's good to know oh why now that's
the tree again I mean let's go this way
then I guess see see what happens I
suppose doesn't where I just came from
is it I have no idea no I shot my
brother I didn't know that
no I don't think this is right okay okay
that's fine that's the PTSD from the
wall
I should i I don't think it's gonna want
me to go back that way no it doesn't
matter that way it's completely
different to what it was anyway [ __ ]
tree again screen got shaky as well
great love it
don't let him see you go out he hadn't
from me though got real shaky that
usually means he's about to hallucinate
I don't know why you want me to go
this is either a maze and I'm failing at
it oh this is exactly what I've
confirmed [ __ ] [ __ ]
pull up my camera
oh that didn't help oh I'm getting a
phone call okay I guess
sheriff laning I thought he was dead oh
good to know
I've been here all night that's very
rude that's the kid that I've been
looking for this whole time with no help
whoa whoa whoa what was that okay and I
like that whispering OH
okay that's a deal
wow this is just suppressive [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay yep they went lying the state
game did get spooky just now [ __ ]
it's the sound design that's getting me
this doesn't [ __ ] I can't turn my lights
off okay chat because then you wouldn't
be able to see me alright I have good
excuses thank you all for joining me I
really appreciate it
one what other time was I supposed to
start this dream oh that's another one
of these get rid of that break it boom
it's always very traumatic when that
happens it's gonna be me isn't it one of
them is gonna be me at some point it's
goddamn pictures okay okay okay okay I
don't like the whispering
[Music]
okay okay oh it's so dark why did I do
this to myself all right that one's yep
good yep we'll have photos of people
standing that's actually my favorite so
what would I care all right Shh I really
have been completely flying playing
through this game up until now great yep
great great great great great great a
text message okay
messages question mark [ __ ] you are you
kidding me oh I hate okay [ __ ] okay
that's not that scary it's a body in a
tree we can recover from that I was
really worried that I have my dead dog
in there
this [ __ ] has been walking
around these woods going crazy for like
several days so I agree Ellis you can't
take it anymore it's been a bad time for
you what is this oh my word that tree is
alive that tree is also alive
I don't want to jump scare you know I
just don't want to deal with it I I will
punch my microphone if I get too scared
do I need to get my camera out still
nothing from the camera I just see vague
movement it doesn't help that my TV
screen is really reflective so I'm just
walking forwards let's see if it does
anything noises are happening that seems
good okay I can't see anything it's
completely black right yeah I can't see
[ __ ] I could be walking into a wall and
I don't know oh that's a light okay
maybe I am going forward Oh somebody's
flash on screen okay okay progress am i
back in the same place [ __ ] you
whisper [ __ ]
okay I'm sorry I take it back
the popper I called you a [ __ ] I didn't
read it I'm really sorry
Oh oh that's me being filmed thank you
for the donation back home good
I appreciate your question about no
man's skies update but now it's not the
time my sweet boy
okay well that was just a tape he'll let
me have done being followed which I
think I already knew but oh I don't want
to turn around I don't like I don't like
it
okay just bow trees it's just the woods
save as always this games just a lot of
woods I feel like I'm really close to
the end but I haven't been to like the
Blair Witch house yet it's just as my
girlfriend I think I don't have a signal
I don't what did you expect Ellis you
idiot you big stupid dummy anybody to
sneeze is that cuz I'm scared I don't
know if that's related okay oh I'm
drowning
great great love it that's one of my
favorite activities to do just like
hobbies I love a good round
oh it's coffee here hey bud
he's a sort of the bad guy who I think
is in cahoots which he tried to make me
kill my dogs I refused naturally cool
yeah is that easy I don't know
I didn't kill Boris did you take his
body I'm gonna need to see it I would
like to see it frankly I wouldn't like
to see it but I don't believe you and I
will not believe you okay okay
a lot okay it seems slightly weird to me
that this name was trying to insult me
by giving me Ellis's backstory I'm like
I don't care about Jess I never even met
oh I've been through this woods the
whole damn time okay that's maybe from
back when he was in a wall and he
stabbed himself so did you stab yourself
I was dumb I've seen that face twice I
think that's Peeta the little boy who's
missing thank you for the donation Shane
I appreciate that
I'm sorry i'm not answering a
super-chill questions right now chat
normally I would but you know tensions
high agree well let you flash like
that's what okay okay let's finish this
damn game boy oh we just walk up here
it's surely it's done soon can't be that
much left really I just haven't counted
the witch yet I guess Kaba
he was like sort of been following me or
whatever has been trying to lead me to
the witch who I think has been
whispering my am but that could also be
Jess who I believe is my girlfriend
don't entirely know though she has
called a few times back at the start of
the game before hallucinations were
constant oh I can't go there okay it
looks like a pop-up though maybe this
way
it's a very fitting for this game but
also mighty annoying that you get lost
in the woods all the goddamn time
surely I'm supposed to go up there
somehow you don't want me to I think
you're wrong I think you do you confuse
yourself video game maybe I was just
walking on in the wrong angle no it's
not letting me get past this I think
that you are incorrect about what you
want me to do
and it's way too goddamn dark for me to
see any different sure that looks like a
pop up the hill
it really does okay is there a way
around this I tried that no oh it's a
dog [ __ ] see anything okay see if
there's another way to go maybe I don't
trust it
oh what's that Oh to stop me from
falling frankly I'd prefer to at this
point what do I need to be alive for hey
don't spoil it Chet I assumed that but
don't tell me alright
that's two I think it was John Powell on
YouTube alright
yes inside gaming did review this game I
wasn't at review that was when I played
like two hours or so evidently I played
a lot more now I am just about to finish
this game okay I don't know why that
didn't work do you want me to walk up
this way that also kind of looks like a
pause okay
no I can't there's no way all right
where else can I go my dudes this also
looks like a pause also blocked um-hmm I
think you're being dumb
oh god I didn't see that before
[ __ ] well okay maybe that's what I
needed to find it's not gonna be useful
she's gonna be like more people
torturing you
oh that's the boy it's called the reveal
that seems climactic okay that's the
house okay he's really a tough day that
Peeta all right call the heck I don't
like any of this
unnecessarily dramatic music the [ __ ] oh
did the world get sideways cool
yeah great well yeah I love it excellent
that's the best I want to see if I can
take these down and honor my dog can't
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay [ __ ] alright well
okay I have nothing to say that will
help give me any solace if I'm being
perfectly honest this is it this is
thank you mr. Petrov ah that did give me
some solace I appreciate that
oh okay okay okay
this is where I expect things to get bad
from what I know of glitch you don't
want to go in the house
you don't want to do it like that
someone walking behind me and I don't
like any of it
[ __ ] I don't want to do this okay just a
video game
I'm gonna turn my brightness up just a
little just thank you yeah
good that actually it didn't make any
difference
okay okay okay why is everything
sideways no what I didn't mean to do
that okay cool
maybe I should watch that tape back see
which way cava actually went oh no it's
right when I see that MOC okay so that's
through the front door he went through
the door on the left
and then I'll wait for his mock on the
wall and then jump ahead to nothing
great great great great well why did it
oh my flashlight alright this one great
yep torch died great great great sick oh
thank you I thought he was gonna throw
them away Jesus Christ idiot okay so the
mocks like help you figure out where to
go and this game for some reason [ __ ] I
hate this
alright alright I hope you're all ok
everyone's being brave more marks that's
what we want it's really hard to
navigate this house this is very small
doorways and that ok good yep good good
love it
yep ok I don't know where to go um and
it's really [ __ ] dog
and uh I just heard somebody stomping
around so I don't know if things could
really get any better
okay that's a bunch of hand prints
that's cool
uh I love it at least you got a sink
yeah that's good ok there's a mark on
that wall so I guess I need to go that
way I stopped looking at the camera I
forgot about it this is right do you you
want me to go this way or is that
because that's the way I came from I
think this is the way I came from huh ok
so we're going back out this way and
then it goes probably up the stairs
all right okay up the stairs might not
be right y'all I can't see any of the
lights I'm supposed to find the little
lines that was supposed to be in the in
the camera have I lost the trail does
seem like something a game would do to
lull you into a false sense of does
another like false sense of security huh
oh okay well it did say Peter was in the
basement which makes downstairs seemed
like a good option
too bad I'm lost okay oh yeah how did I
get lost that fast oh oh okay
okay that's gonna be used for something
thank you for the donation you couldn't
see your name
albanist Jack he said I should make the
controls and voted to make it spooky
just like Matt peek I will not why is
there a maka there there's nothing I can
do about this you know what think nope
this sucks this sucks hot I probably
didn't need that key though um maybe I
need that for the basement so I'm and
just go back downstairs and everything's
gonna be fine right right right
guys am i right not that I have any idea
where it is for the record I think I've
looked everywhere in here though so I
guess I have to go back okay okay oh
this is it
this is the doll that's it boyos I hate
it I hate I hate all of this I hope that
I walk down there and someone's standing
in a corner and that's the end of this
game that's what I want because that'd
be very Blair would she and not that
scary you know it's crazy I don't think
anything's gonna hurt me I'm just scared
anyway why am I so what am I scared of
it's a video game
what's what's scary Ilana nothing what's
the problem
okay okay the signs are pointing to both
of these don't
Thank You beach' and thank you Brian I
appreciate it
I'm so sorry that you just came back
from overseas and this is the first
thing you're watching um I don't know
what to make of this like do you want me
to go this way now maybe oh that's still
locked okay so this way it still is done
okay
okay that's cool I love that
[Music]
that one was different they like just
made it Angry [ __ ] I have to get rid of
my torch oh I think that's the first
jump scare of this whole game okay I
can't tend to torch I know I mean can I
get through there no doubt that was that
was the play which one it what happened
dad I was bad lighting oh cool that's
great I love it when that happens
okay okay
Thank You Chad for reminding me that B
is for Bruce B is for brave bee bee bee
bee bee like Burt what would Bruce do he
wouldn't have frozen right here that's
okay it's gonna happen again isn't it
okay I think I can probably do juice
that that Lloyd light
what is he Lloyd that Lloyd means that
it does Blair which is is nearby she may
be in this room [ __ ] me
thank you so just pretend you bought
this house then it's more angering how
bad it looks in spooky okay yeah Bruce
would probably do that
Oh twitch chat is there a delay that's
because I'm playing through an al gato
so that means that the gameplay is just
like on a it's almost a second of lag
people complain about it in my videos
all the time but that is not for me to
do about it
well not that I've figured out yet I
think I fixed it for my Sakura video
but it's uh just just always happens
[ __ ] I hate this oh well that's probably
where I have to go huh
okay of course it is of course of course
it is of course it is okay we need to
find a [ __ ] key and this piece [ __ ]
house I do not want to be here that's
the basement and slopped Brad B's Bruce
[ __ ] brave that's not gonna work
there was only one other room to go in
and it was this one I think oh we're
almost finished this video game I am
pretty sure also I hope cuz I want to
die
alright interactive tapes okay that's
gonna be that dole maybe so probably
need to do it about well now I probably
need to wait for the whole thing to fall
oh okay yes open
I guess I just watch the whole thing
okay we need to open that for those just
joining us who have not played this game
basically the red tapes effect the
environment oh why does it just does it
just get is it getting dark music don't
like it don't like it okay this door is
open now that's what I wanted isn't it
Thank You Steven do I ever think about
the fact that I could market condoms at
teenage boys where while they're asleep
as dream catches I hadn't but I will let
myself be distracted by that for a few
moments okay let's continue I feel like
I should my foot was up right near my TV
and I'm worried something's gonna jump
out I'm gonna kick my [ __ ] TV this
way he marked the what Peter I'm only
here for you and bullet if you don't
show yourself I am going to [ __ ]
leave well I hate that what did you get
shocked by he shocked me because he said
what the prick
okay child screaming okay just gonna
find the kid gonna leave fine the kid
dad the [ __ ] stop crouching because
that makes you walk weird oh oh well I
can't I see excellent I have to turn
around I love it when you make me Duke
maybe have to look up who's this the pot
from the tape maybe don't think so okay
cool cool cool cool cool cool best video
game I've ever played in my whole life
what was that
I'm looking at the stream because it's
so delayed that something moved right I
missed it I still missed it mm-hmm ah
it is the house rebuilding itself
actually not mad about it no frankly on
board now I'm scared of windows though
so you did that to me and I wasn't
previously okay
Oh maybe I was a cop I didn't actually
realize that it gives you power it gives
you a chance to hold life in your palm
you touch the twigs and you run your
fingers through that bones you brush
them down you break the spine she
watches you once you pick them up she
won't let you put them down and her
whispers become sweeter every time you
clench your fist oh so by picking those
up I was [ __ ] myself great well
that's good to know
you do make us sound nice though like
she gets sweeter every time Oh No
again actually fine with this that's the
frame rate drop right there yeah this
games pretty broken
just let me why did music why did do
music why would you do that to me okay
thank you John he said IGN misses you I
appreciate that
all right well duh okay cool great the
camera is not picking anything up this
is the most positive thing anyone said
to me in months okay
I
women are so demanding I don't like that
it went silent look that's why it went
silent okay okay this is fine it was
better before but still fine stuck on
the door frames Ellis you idiot okay
cool
she kept me out oh oh that I scared
myself then that was my own fault you
are for her sure she can do what she
wants to me Dad [ __ ] how freaky is it
can I up in a stool what did you just
sup [ __ ] okay cool yeah alright love it
yeah I played PT I don't like those
windows though okay great oh I'm so
tense okay anything any writing to
arouse me in here she did she leave me
any sexts you that's some Resident Evil
7 nonsense right there you're gonna make
me eat that food if I walk in this room
I maintain [ __ ] be crazy
they do just easy good I think I keep
having to sneeze cuz I'm scared I feel
like okay got it got another text from
no way that's calls okay from Jess it's
just too much I can't take it anymore I
won't let you drag me down with you that
[ __ ] just broke up with me it's fine I
have a new girlfriend now she's making
me chase her around oh we had haunted
house but at least she wants me I don't
love you anymore
great no this would be a great game to
play like right after a breakup thank
you for the donation sketch Bruce's
training me in the way of bravery don't
let the demons rustle you Jimmy's be the
Jimmy Russell Oh Bruce tried you know he
did he tried he tried his best I can't
tell you it worked
okay that's chill good sounds
everybody's having a good time did I go
the wrong way
oh [ __ ] great yeah okay cool
that's locked this is still open just
let me go I don't want to be here you
know thank you for the energy chat I
really appreciate it okay see I like
that I can fake bravery by looking at
what the chat saying you're all fooled
right your all your all definitely like
oh no she's not scared she's just
interacting with her audience
wow what a great content create a [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
that's a great gravestone no okay
that's a man my nails got real messed up
at some point during this ordeal
I expected that okay it's one thing that
I think Bluebird team does really well
which is a little hotter in this game
since it's so up and oh I will take that
rare achievement
thank you what an uplifting thing to
happen Dimond achievement
yeah okay okay okay I think he might
have told me to hit the gym because I
used to be perfect
I'll take the money okay
okay okay okay oh that's cool
this game just did a time loop that's a
conversation I had with someone on this
radio oh they are in the game that's
very cool
okay is this different something
exploded behind me um okay how long have
I been playing this full 40 minutes that
checks out I expected this to take a hot
while maybe 20 minutes left
should I be retracing my steps here I
don't know it sounded like something
like broke the building right but I
don't want to make the mistake of going
backwards if that's not what I'm
supposed to be doing let's double-check
this way
what was the 300 full oh that a joke oh
thank you catch out em Aaron
I appreciate that friends thank you guys
so much for everyone freaking out about
that 300 is I think it's not us dollars
300 but either way thank you so much
okay
this is maybe what happened and where
I'm supposed to be going right now okay
great
big dock space that's cool I guess I'll
go down another hallway cool broken
chair oh okay
this is the sheriff he's been dead for a
while
I can't support you as an individual
anymore Ellis the sheriff was a great
guy he didn't did I kill him he's not
what this game is telling me did I kill
him I not realize that I did that [ __ ]
okay
be always careful
be aware careful of what I don't know
what you want from me like okay message
is are you a good man Ellis I don't know
you seem to think I [ __ ] been
murdering people this whole time you
look you dead okay
what does that mean is something that I
can't look at I don't know dude uh we
don't need to walk forward looking down
don't look follow the path okay you made
me look I didn't choose to do that
Thank You Leucadia hey fun house made me
start a YouTube channel that's the best
thank you so much that is very cool to
you okay follow the path will not look
at the scary monster I don't want to
anyway
I think that static means I'm like super
close to it though okay
it's it this would be a great time for a
jump-scare because uh oh
you later me downstairs and I didn't
realize because I'm so fixated on the
ground okay boss following the pot still
[ __ ] still doing it okay
you're gonna I know you're gonna give me
a jump scare there's no way it's not
gonna happen I mean he can keep giving
me money it's fine
I don't really need a husband I'm good
but thank you I'll just um keep taking
you to dollar store it's cool by me okay
well how do you how do you propose I do
that the tapes
that's not what I wanted at all watch
tapes there's the part where the house
fell on itself it's not gonna fix it
probably not
[Music]
cuz this doesn't look like that like I
could try it
Hey well I feel like this might kill me
no I didn't really have a choice we're
doing it all right how do you have so
many levels are you know house is in
middle of nowhere it's gonna breathe
it's being rich but okay all right what
still walking my lad look yet you want
clear on if I would die if I looked now
that pulse is still there did I do
something wrong
music died thank you Roman I am very
chill it's true if I were to wait what
if I were to describe my personality
with one word it would be the word chill
okay okay okay okay
why now yeah still here okay
love it huge fan of that that's great
which way from here dope you're gonna
need to give me some more I'm not
allowed to look oh the doll checks out
okay
know where the where did the lines go I
don't want to get lost in here okay
upstairs okay this is the right way to
go though oh it is confirmed confirmed
confirmed noise happened great love it
all right Thank You Matthew
I appreciate that I'll probably be at
the Sunshine Coast in and for Christmas
no this isn't great because like if one
of them's here I'm just gonna run into
it because I don't know where I'm
[ __ ] going son of a [ __ ]
I don't want this great
yeah that's done yeah no we love that
here but we're all happy about that
happening [ __ ] me oh this is such a dick
move that's why it's a [ __ ] dick move
who is Adam Kovac okay I need to look
down do I still need to look down I'm
very unclear on the rules Oh
all right great I guess I'm allowed to
look up now what trying to kill me I
killed man and if you've already
established that I think I killed like
several whole dudes okay great great
so wow that's a lot of blood
I feel like the plot of this game might
be that Ellis is a piece of [ __ ] that's
a lot of blood
but you know I'm just out here yep hey
bud
that sure is me just out here trying to
find PETA okay cool
is this gonna be on me Adam is this who
I killed
thank you back salon which got me speak
more this so until dawn uh I don't know
uh until dawn has a lot more jump scares
I guess but this this game again up
until this point was not scary at all
okay that would have been really intense
if they made him black very intentional
move to make him the white dude named
Adam so I guess I had PTSD from the wall
and then I shot a dude who was not armed
in the [ __ ] head um that me not what
I'm about good old alley boy walking
through this house trying to avoid dying
just looking for a kid just hoping to
find a kid Thank You Leonardo you didn't
know it's kami but thank you okay it's
getting old Arkham Asylum now who needs
this many chairs what are you just
popular how many friends do you have I
guess you didn't that's a bit too much
exposition for my liking [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you yeah we've seen a lot of this before
Ellis
oh okay I've seen a few of those in my
time can't break that all right well
this is escalating
that's the Sutton uh-huh great love it
[ __ ] this
okay there's nothing else for me to
interact with other than that it seems I
feel like it's too quiet [ __ ] dude
she's gonna show up she's gonna show up
she's gonna yep I know it
that me a soldier who I think killed
some people
no that's the soldiers Oh No okay that
was just a game being dumb no stuck on a
doorframe again Oh Ellis okay
[Music]
thanks I hate it oh it is just someone
staring at a blank wall which which
which thank you Dan I don't know about
that but thank you okay it's [ __ ]
because I killed some people yeah I'm
sure you're a saint you're in here with
a big-ass gun who asks for that where am
I supposed to go just just don't did I
punch that guy okay hello yes good yes
excellent all right okay okay okay okay
okay okay yep this is quite a trip this
game very much ramped up in intensity so
this is from his time in the wall I
guess the problem with it is that I'm
not attached to Ellis as a character in
the slightest so I'm like you're a dick
whatever
okay little LSE boy I've been through
the war ready it's not gonna get one
[Music]
audio cues oh I guess he's all up full
vocal cool cool cool tight tight tight
tight tight I guess these are the names
all of all the boys in his squad who I
believe died because he did something
wrong
great oh this is the basement Peter I'm
coming for you and also probably some
more scary [ __ ] that's picked by the my
own movement in the war great okay yep
okay sure
this game just keeps nagging me and you
know what it is working I do want to
date it okay okay yep great amateur
talents not that far off base frankly
not that insulting I prefer to be an
amateur than a murderer okay which
allowed them to conduct a surprise
attack combatants killed in action yeah
I didn't mention all that names I know
that I ordered them to do something that
led to them dying
and I like it when it gets quiet you
guys that's what I don't like my
stomach's been so tensed for so long
because I'm just having a bad bad time
who was that
should I recognize whoever that was I
don't okay is that it no you're gonna
need to give me more okay yep good no no
the dole great great great staircase
again okay do what you're gonna make me
kill someone else this [ __ ] man
nothing startles me more than having a
door slammed in my face just rude you
know you just recoiled from how impolite
it was I think I just jumped it nothing
Burke okay am I gonna kill Peter is that
what you want me to do yeah [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you bullet doesn't like them so
they're dying I don't care I don't care
if it strengthens your hold on me bullet
doesn't like them
alrighty alrighty okay great more of the
same [ __ ] hallways oh this is the room
that was on the tape ex do I want it to
be ruined
I mean I guess yeah okay well we have
been walking around the same house for
uh epi' okay I'm gonna bring it back up
and then walk through here and then cave
it in maybe let's try that
Hey so now I'm on this side and this is
open okay okay okay
it got real quiet again ladies and
gentlemen
oh also just so you guys know my the the
screen I was using to read to read the
chat died so I'm really doing the rest
of this completely alone okay
we got a [ __ ] text again he is here
yo shadow I think I hate that I was less
scared of the witch speaking on sultry
to me my shadow
well he look kind of cute okay all right
you want me to get around this somehow I
don't know I'm gonna do that that was
gonna be tough okay go through this way
oh wait where did it go where did the
lines go what wait what what have I done
lines are you to wimps do they lead this
way this is why this thing [ __ ] shows
up it's over there I can't get through
here though right
like this might kill me unless there is
another way around no that's right again
I guess no no it's not gonna work for me
okay let's just be real careful I
suppose not fond of my chances but we
are doing okay you get out all right I
think we got out cameras freaking out
cuz it was really close well we did it
okay that's chill I was looking down so
I didn't see it alright what do you want
[ __ ] why is that glowing I don't like
any of this just [ __ ] get me out of
here please just can you imagine doing
this in real life
can you imagine how awful that would be
God okay
you just walk around a house that you
forever get lost in because it's a hell
made scape wet definitely walking in
suckle zealous buddy old boy chappie old
pal
no police there are actual arrows now
I'm not convinced that this stupid kid
is worth any of this though Peter could
grow up to be a cook and it would be all
your fault if you save him now we can't
handle more [ __ ] in the world I don't
mind her talking actually she sounds
kind of cute it's better than nothing I
just I just want to get out I just I
just want to find out what happened to
my dog Oh careful okay no looking we're
not looking we're looking at the ground
it's a great game play for the people at
home to watch because we can't [ __ ]
look at anything that means it's a
monster Namie I don't know where he is
though so it's a bit hard to avoid him
okay stick as close to the line as I
possibly [ __ ] can
alright you getting through the lists a
couple more okay I think that don't
looks might be exclusive to those rooms
you think the last ones name was like
Sebastian or something [ __ ] door okay
Sylvester I forgot about Rosco
you did because cool well least you
admitted it I think he already knew that
though and I think that's actually even
necessarily true
I think man's just made a mistake he's
still beating himself up for it that's
the real tragedy of the Blair Witch
calman cannon for this game universe
okay we've already been here who's room
what do you know something that I do not
who was he
wait is a boy which a man and I just
didn't know could be all right I feel
like you want me to interact with
something you know there we go okay
that's gonna be all the dead soldiers
maybe back out we go
yeah army barracks again I respect it I
just don't care enough about Ellis to
get invested in this storyline cool
yeah show almost people is selfish all
right well thank you well the moderate
one still gets me I don't want to be
playing as a murderer in a video game
great
I love that this is how I would decorate
my own home did I just die nope still in
the same [ __ ] house I I missed the
woods I never thought that I would but
he'll be [ __ ] off that's bad okay
is this the decaying of my mind which we
are witnessing firsthand here I hate
that yeah that can't go [ __ ] itself [ __ ]
me
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
yeah keep making me it turns me on
that's I would love to date you call me
a failure a couple more times he's
supposed to sandwich it they want you
like if someone's negging you they're
supposed to give you [ __ ] like um like
oh good you're eating a salad or
something it's supposed to be like Hoffa
a compliment you're just calling me a
murderer in selfish and [ __ ] useless and
whatever oh my god I feel like I'm
getting a workout with how much I'm
sweating and panicking oh okay okay
back out wait get all the doors
disappear they did they super did
don't keep it dull can jump out nope
okay that's fine all right
this isn't like my ideal date but I'll
take what I can get can I walk over this
yeah in my experience Ellis is
notoriously bad at moving over things
great great
who dat but but who is she what are you
gonna sell now Hey okay oh it's just
fine great
yep we know whoa all right
well it's just like Petey that's so cute
I wish I could sprint I can uh-huh
we're gonna sprint through this boys
okay
not another one what does that we read
the text so what is it gonna tell me to
not know nope no phone I don't know dude
like a murderer I guess but I don't care
OOP
I sold him already why did she make me
look at him I would never do that no
careful okay okay be very careful okay
woman everyone else is telling me I'm
selfish and a murderer and saying they
hate me oh I look dead okay well okay
yeah this is this woman having any
vested interest in me is a new thing for
me
women usually don't give a [ __ ] about me
at all
[Music]
and again everyone else keeps calling me
a [ __ ] coward
so this one's great actually he said
gone well okay nothing that's see I
would way prefer the witch just take me
to her what do I care not
if the sound could stop making me jump
ooh was not a naked lady is that huh
because actually I take back everything
that I said she did not look hot that
[ __ ] looked old and witchy and a little
bit like a granny wait what oh those are
some footsteps
yeah okay
well not a huge fan of that but I will
do my best
[ __ ] [ __ ] I can't get through that way
obviously [ __ ] I'm worried that if I
look up I'll die because this game is
not established rules oh hey you uh no
didn't look at you but fine why fine um
okay you have to find a way around how
many tapes aren't gonna help me earlier
like he might be very close
I don't it's not that way it's
definitely to the left somehow
I think that guys also to the left so
we're gonna just go this way and then no
[Music]
I think that means I'm super close to
him
okay did I do it no [ __ ] just came into
the same room [ __ ] uh okay I mean it has
to be from that way
I just don't know how to get there hey
bud
I suspect you oh very close by
but I'm not really sure how to avoid you
is that it oh thank [ __ ] okay I'm trying
like I'm trying super hard well so what
do you want me to do is it kill the kid
[ __ ] be texting me all the time you
can't look at yourself in the mirror
anymore can you
I actually have no idea what I look like
I have not seen myself in this video
game even one time [ __ ] you know who's
a [ __ ] the Blair Witch kill me okay
great great great great great okay yep
excellent all right back out we go
should I go this way maybe I don't like
it when you kill the audio it makes me
really nervous straight ahead okay yeah
cool what's this another red tape okay
okay okay that's me or that's here he
goes left
okay we got to make that room explode
[ __ ]
get in the corner don't look it up
oh it's trying to pull me away that's
cool
no I don't want to no no no I do not
want sued I would like to continue
lifting forward please she gone
I will take that as a yes
doesn't seem like a smart idea to just
turn around though it does it sort of
feel like we don't have a choice
all right [ __ ] did it like get daca
cuz I love that okay I don't have any
sympathy for you I just I'm here to find
Peter
okay okay okay what's this great yep
good okay all right sweet love love it
whoa thought it was a person it was not
I I - I'm going crazy I guess caught up
where's your mom no
whoa trippy I'm gonna go through the
opened door okay
good thing I don't get motion sick cuz
damn alright okay
you have no chill well nothing's more
terrifying than a sliding chair oh my
god okay oh oh I 2m slighty I'm a
slighty boy okay all right Oh Peter
Peter Peter [ __ ] [ __ ] man I totally feel
like I'm going crazy with him right now
am I gonna know okay well I can't get
there so that's just rude it's okay
great uh [ __ ] Oh speedy that's a lot of
red just written okay opening the door
oh my god I'm exhausted
this is a lot of tension I know you
think I'm the murderer I kind of feel
similarly okay I have to look at the
blood okay [ __ ] me all right oh those
are those eyes I keep seeing yeah his
hands have been through some [ __ ] dude
oh that's just a lot of tetanus okay
[ __ ] yeah I'm back here again are we
and all right I can't pick that up this
time bye uh that's a cute oh it's not on
the camera Cabo's lifts you what you've
deduced is it old LSE boy that's
breathing
yep good I don't know what you want me
to do you keep telling me to do
something is it kill myself
crushed something in my hands that's
what you wanted
kill them all that makes sense
Wow okay well I think I'm doing that but
I don't know why I'm doing that y'all
done broke my camera this was like at
least $20 back in 99
think about it Ellis who who are we
killing here though who is it that you
really want to kill oh that was it just
trees and I mind if we kill those
actually I'm kind of in support of that
mmm
lost again are we good
wait can I decay things yeah I guess
okay no no all right this is the same
room I got lost in before how many
levels of stairs do you have in this
house when I was outside it looked like
about two floors and now we've walked
down maybe ten sets of staircases son of
a look okay thank you well that was nice
I guess being a murderer isn't that bad
I am become the witch I killed him I did
kill that man I felt it I also broke
that window this is actually pretty dope
is this do you think what being a Super
Saiyan is like
oh so that was the dude I shot and then
one of my soldiers so it's making me
relive my motives I guess question mark
maybe I couldn't find a way out from
here that where where are we supposed to
be going here France I do not know I
lost much oh oh oh oh my glitter yeah
yeah okay I'm just retracing my steps
now but maybe it wants me to who [ __ ]
knows nope it doesn't and you don't want
me to go back upstairs to you
did I miss a doll what did I what did I
miss
wait wait wait wait it's vibrating I
just did something I don't know what I
vote I don't know what I did but
something died
it's just the same rooms over and over
and over again
Alice buddy that's just some sheets you
tried to no we didn't try to go through
here because I thought it was blocked oh
wait no okay okay good we figured it out
I'm a genius
I got it sorted yeah cool dad
should I maybe like be trying to not
kill them
I know this game has multiple endings
and I know that I'm doing a bad job
I got power-hungry you know I just I
couldn't help it
I could kill people with a camera and I
really overcame me and I guess this is
what I'm about now basement okay okay
yeah I don't know dude I I - and
tripping balls
alright the basement
Peter you little [ __ ] this is gonna be a
[ __ ] huge basement doing it Peter
Peter where are you I mean listen my man
cutlass okay
logic tells me your boys long dead I
actually don't know how that didn't
occur to you it's locked okay find a key
he's clearly down there stupid [ __ ] do I
have to do all the thinking it's like
living with an idiot yes yes that's
totally what I thought yeah why just be
fine once okay no thanks there's so
anime so am i Alastair type all right
let's have sex let's get it done with
this games been full of tension between
these two dude bros so let's just
[ __ ] do it let's get it done wit put
your dick in another man and then get
the boy back he'd been out in this woods
for a long time you just need somebody
to love okay
this can't be good the it's nothing
feels good about this can I go back to
the part where I was like setting people
on fire with my camera because that was
super cool maybe I have allergies maybe
that's what this DS is all I have no
idea all right
back at the wall okay yeah we've done
this before it just turned into call of
duty oh wait wait we're outside the
house now oh this is simulating nope
nope okay just back in the woods
PTSD is super fun for everyone support
that's in that
Hey Carver kept you waiting huh oh well
yeah it's hard to fight a man when you
hallucinate constantly okay oh that's
the woman I keep saying that's the eyes
I keep seeing I'm not seeing him a point
out does he kill her he killed her
why would he do that is that did you he
probably killed outta silence huh
oh is that an accident I'm very unclear
on what just happened all right mate
cool cosplay because now he's she's
bothering Ellis take his face okay I
don't mean to kink shame but that's a
bit much support your sexual fantasies
does a kid here someone oh sweet baby oh
oh oh no is he scared if we know
oh well is that the end of the game I
think it might be it is Ellis gave into
his rage and despair the cycle continues
Kabul was born again despite his
injuries bullet survived success I feel
like that was a bad ending just cut all
the ties with Ellis after learning his
fate she didn't say a word
what was his fate never found Peeta this
seems like it was a bad ending I know
this game was multiple endings but I
don't feel good about this one it's no
clues to its whereabouts sheriff
lanning's body was never recovered from
the Black Hills forest Todd mckennon's
body was found months later in the taffy
East Creek sawmill so rotten it was
Neely I don't remember who sheriff
landing I remember Todd McKinnon I don't
my boo that is
definitely seems like a bad ending I may
have [ __ ] up was it because I found
the people with the camera I'm really
sorry about that all right we did it we
finished it plots are there I'm not
gonna lie you guys I did get spooked my
MacBook battery died so I can't read
chat so I will stop this stream and then
start another one to see the chat for a
bit but for now yike I mean how many
okay let's see how good this game
actually is that's not a good amount of
achievements no that's not enough
finishing a game you only get to 35 dog
I would have liked find out what
happened to PETA
I didn't get that ending find out what
happened to bullet so but didn't I find
out what happened a bullet I guess I
didn't find out what hurt him so I guess
those uh well hang on
what's the completion rate for finishing
the game okay no so I guess those are
separate endings is finding out what
happened to either of those which I
somehow didn't get huh I remember a
pizza guy pitches all right thank you
for supporting me through this wild
journey people I'll see y'all next time
good day
[Music]